what's up guys today has been a very
busy day over at barbell HQ um just
working on a on a lot of new launches
happening all while um getting some
backyard Furniture
delivered I ordered this back in
September it's not even the whole thing
yet um and they just delivered a couple
pieces so you see that Lonely Boy there
with the plastic covering that's one of
them it's like a tandem not a tandem but
it's a side by side
um it's perfect in the winter you know
what I mean for all the swimming we're
going to be doing this December and
January and stuff I can't wait to use it
being
sarcastic um and yeah look at that we
got Christmas up not completely up we're
still on November as soon it was like
November 1 or something I'm like that's
it putting all the Halloween [__] away
we're bringing out the Christmas stuff
so I'm like about 50% done with the
Christmas stuff but today is Thursday
and Thursday whenever Papa's in town we
try to make it a date a lunch date so
Papa and I are going on a lunch date I
didn't have enough time to get ready
because I was saying I was a little bit
busy so this is all he's
getting this is it this the
Luke did you dress for our
date no oh I usually would but it feels
like we're in such a rush and I was like
okay do I want to spend time and then
cut into our daytime or do I just want
to rock very sentimental that MRA got me
cuz she bought me the sweater I did look
at that Jordan lifting undefeated you
know what I'm saying and I smell good
too I already smell watch smell
me I only smell myself oh well I always
already what are you
wearing uh you
say yeah I don't know what I'm wearing I
don't know which one maybe it's DOL
Ching I don't know which one I like
getting my scents in
Asia scents not scents scents in Asia
cuz they have like so many different
lighter sweeter softer smelling scents I
gu specifically like Japan Taiwan when I
went why I like getting the scents there
cuz they just smells so much lighter and
refreshing whereas out here I mean we
have really nice ones too um but I just
I don't know I just feel like it's too
strong for me where is [__]
wasn't he just talking about oh s and I
just don't want to spend day look at me
I'm just [__] standing outside hello
hello oh I got to explain the blue
tape at some point today I'll explain it
you're making me wait I'm looking for
yummy food oh we could be doing that
together am I driving or you're driving
I'm driving what but you know the minute
we move we lose internet and then it's
hard to look so I want to find the spot
before right
okay we're going to figure out what
we're going to eat we have no [__]
clue we're get a
date okay so we decided on Ramin have
you had that
Ramin why are you saying a Japanese word
with a French accent because I was just
trying to throw you off really say
something else in another accent go here
say um say say quesadilla in your best
African accent go oh my God I don't even
know an African accent to bad you got
you you dug this hole you got to do
it damn that was racist what that was
the most racist ever no really yeah you
just made fun of all the Chinese people
in the world you said African accent and
I don't know why you had to bring out
the gong but you
did
what are you [__] with me you you're
so stupid okay but you tell me you rate
it you rate your your African accent was
that good yo let me hear you say Kad in
and African accent I didn't dig the hole
you dug no [__] go say it go dat's
going so good every time every we if we
look back at every one of these videos
it's just us talking [__] to each other
what is it go okay let me see let me
see first I got to get in the zone okay
yeah let me see the racist [__] you're
about to
do okay that's a cute rot weather
okay
okay what's how's that different than
what I
[Music]
said you don't have to pull your eyes
they already pull that's what you did no
I didn't F you do it again no
way that's what you were doing yeah
that's racist [__] man we're going to go
get Ramen okay all right so we are in
the freaking in dead center of Chinatown
in Vegas which is called Spring Valley
or Spring Mountain or Spring Valley and
Spring Mountain Road yeah
and that removes all hesitation if it's
going to be good cuz for a Asian Spot to
last in this town it needs to be good
like this part of town has all the good
Asian spots so I don't [__] around so I
mean if you look like this you better be
[__] knowing what you're doing so
it's
called um I saw your
iPhone yes the iPhone tacos no it's
called oh right there Shoku Ramen and
what's cool is I found out this place is
actually 24/7 so for those of you guys
that like to party you want to get some
hot soup 24/7 but it has 4 and a half
stars at 2,000
reviews so this might be like the the
[__] long of ramen [__] them long if
everyone ever has come to Vegas and you
better you everyone knows [__] long
and if you try to get some f we've been
getting [__] long for like I don't
know for 10 years yeah a minute every
time we came here we would get it you
ready for some Shoku Ramen yeah all
right this place is kind of cool cuz
it's like a build your own Ramen style
so you pick your broth you got miso
tonkotsu um if you like shinsen or daia
that's that style I was hoping they had
a showyou which is like a clear soy
sauuce fro they
but they do have shio so I like shio too
so I'll get that then you pick your
noodles then you pick your protein and
all the toppings that your heart desires
so this is pretty cool where like
sometimes you order Ramen and you want
to like pick and choose things and you
want to customize and they can't a lot
of Japanese places are like this is how
I want eat this is how you going to eat
it that's racist what do you mean I had
to get you back no no that's Jose the
guy in the
back guara so that's how they do it but
this one just from the start you get to
customize I did see on yel they Shoku
tacos dumpling skin tacos with pork
green onion inside of housemade CA sauce
it look delicious it look crispy so I'm
going to have to get this and then also
I saw something else outside did you see
what I saw outside the desert
outside yeah you [__]
Asian that was racist no I I just was
describing you oh you're an Asian that's
what I said what are you going to get B
uh I don't know I think I'm going to get
the Tatu and that's as far as I got cuz
somebody told me
to I was going to say our fingers
touched and I choke them as
Sal what a loser you get some cut I
didn't get that far cuz somebody was
like oh turn on the camera I have
something to say you read that slow like
a slow
Mexican that was fast
wow pouring my drinks this is how you
properly pour a
Sprite you know that's not true really
well cuz you want the gases to release
so that the gases aren't trapped in your
stomach so what you're going to do now
all day is I'm probably going to be
bloated thank you thank you so much that
one's yours you want are you serious
yeah all right that's why when they
teach you how to pour the beer like that
it's all wrong cuz then that's when you
feel all
bloated what's
happening feel
this okay of course why is one all cold
and one all warm [__] [__] trying to
[__] me
excuse me what wait
what that's what I'm talking about Gess
it up oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] you didn't
know the
bartend a bartend that doesn't drink I
know look at that beautifully for I love
it here bikini Mama here's your spr
thank you baby little stir what's the
stir
for
the first Ishu is up chicken KAG Papa's
going to hook it up with some Lemo I
don't think it's one of the things
they're known for I usually only get the
things they're known for it's my first
time but I was just in the mood for K
and you asked me if I wanted something I
was like nah I don't care I'm going get
anywhere and you got
it but the spicy Ms really good yeah try
it see what it's like oh you know how
chicken K is hot as hell when it first
comes out burn me try it try
[Music]
it P you oh man I saw that saw that
steam yeah I saw that steam come out of
your mouth
[Music]
yummy what is that this is what I'm
really excited for on a bunch of the
Yelp photos they showed tacos at a Ramen
spot I was like tacos at a Ramen spot
and it's cuz they fried The Dumpling
skin and that's the
shashu so first and foremost I need to
take a picture cuz you know how my Asian
ass
is
[Music]
damn okay you want to do the honors nope
I want to eat the Kur I got to try this
what is this salsa verde Japanese
[Music]
stuff
all right here goes nothing Japanese
[Music]
tacos well what is it like what does it
taste like what's going on so it really
literally is like a taco but with
Japanese flavor like Japanese pork belly
with the onions and like so it's like if
you guys couldn't tell that the thing
with the tortilla folded and then Stu
inside is a taco I'm glad Bart was able
to shut some light on yeah it's actually
a taco thank you he told us nothing
about the flavors I have no idea what to
expect is it
good a new expi I don't know how to try
it know what me look at that mouth like
imagine I stuck my thumb in your butt
how would you describe that so
much pretty easily how
describe it without describing the
physical emotions yeah thank you and we
got a drowning that's also something
they're known for it's toss and like
sesame oil ponzo you got to eat try you
try this yeah here you try this th in
the butt got it you try it and you tell
me how you would describe it here's some
of the their Japanese salsa
[Applause]
bir I actually really like it w it's
spicy
and what kind of meat is it what's the
prote pork belly I think chashu
probably these the driest ones
I've ever had okay here we
[Applause]
go describe
it isn't it hard it's spicy I think it
was it spicy well I don't know it's that
spicy it's really ready so you're just
going to describe it as spicy it's like
a crispy won
filling no it's not it tastes like a
taco bow Japanese
style it's a wanton outer skin
Oh you try one of the uh drowning gas
then okay this looks really good look at
that I like how manyy they gave too
usually there's only like six of them
it's like a legit
appetizer
it's good that was really
good you ate it in two pieces it's
really hot look at all that
steam it's really really good wow really
good wow so Mama went with like their
standard signature Ramen the ichiu or
something let me try the
broth
this o wow want me clear these out of
your way H yeah look that look at that
shredded
OCTA o fried garlic
too and I like the diced onions that's
awesome oh and I love the I love the egg
like this so when I go to a new
restaurant I always ask what's the most
popular dish cuz if they made a name for
themselves I want to know what they
based it off of and they said this
oxtail thing I was in the mood for sh
which is like really light and it's
completely opposite but I always have to
go the other way well I got to try the
oale does the soup taste different than
yours yours is good yeah maybe it's
because of the garlic oh yeah the fried
garlic
I go for it Papa okay they said this is
their number one dish oh look at this
shredded OCT
tail
M it's a good
flavor
[Music]
I was in a sandwich mood I hope you know
but I love you so much when you said no
sandwiches I was like it's all right
I'll do whatever mama likes I asked if
you wanted to get him you're like no I'm
just throwing it out there that's your
bad our date's going so B you you can't
complain now a great date what you
brought it literally mid bite you wanted
to start fighting you had a mouthful of
oxtail
meat this is good flavor you son of a
[__] you know I'm just going to cut it
right now no one gives a [__] what you
have to say are you sure about
that noodles all can you go sit across
from me I don't even want to see you you
got get like this
this so the date was very Cy but the
food I can't see I want to go back out
of five stars I think I would probably
give it a two damn like that trying to
make go out of business [__] you want to
give him a three yeah I'll probably give
him a three okay A 2 and a half yeah I
was think so this highly rated um but I
got Exquisite taste buds which you
always trust me but I'm thinking maybe
because it is a 24-hour place people
come from the club or the casino drunk
late at night and like oh this is Bomb I
can totally see it being like like good
in that way but if I were to compare it
to some of the best ramen I've had it's
probably like three out of five and I've
been to Japan you know what I'm saying
plan and now papa wants to go to seven
leaf take it away it's cuz honestly I
line up my cheat days with our date days
and I eat pretty clean so I was like you
know I've been wanting Boba for about a
week now so I should probably get that
fixed all right Baran what did you order
I got the Assam and you got the Jasmine
yeah I got a Jasmine te with Boba no cuz
I don't I think we might have it
switched let me
see it's labeled yeah yeah look aam and
then mine says Jasmine oh okay and the
Jasmine is pretty
bomb This Ss all right this one's really
good I made a good choice I'd give this
one a five out of
five that's should have that one see
maybe you should trust my ratings but I
got my little Boba fists and then we got
macarons we got Mao B no I was trying to
do the different accent with the
actual
maon can you do this can you
go oh yeah you can do it there's a lot
of languages that do that you know that
yeah or when I got something stuck in my
throat I also do that ta does it all the
time macarons like that yeah well I got
some macarons for taica yeah cuz right
now we've um now it's time to pick him
up from school we started a little date
a little bit later so we're going to go
straight pick him up and I feel [__]
up going with this he can't have any cuz
it's caffeinated uh so I got him a
little oh is that why you got it what
the [__] that's uni you're so slow no I
thought you got it just cuz you wanted
it no I got it for him you're so sweet
you're a good Mama no [__] who do you
think I am you you were just going to
get this for yourself you didn't think
of your son when you know you're going
to see him right now you know I make it
disappear before I when I see him I'm
like hey what's up he goes hey papa why
do you smell milk tea and boba in your
mouth I'm like what are you talking
about
that's [__]
up all right so this is the sexiest date
ever shut up we're on the way to pick
and T up better pass it up and now my
wife say she needs to take a fat [__] go
going please we're trying to find a
clean bathroom look at how slow you're
going go that way I
know we got to think go bad ass [__] you
are playing too Goddamn much what are
you talking about go in front of the car
I got you good luck baby so [__]
sexy D you better not come out the brown
stain how did it
go God that was a close call you are
such a sexy date I didn't even see
anyone's faces I just like was like
zoned in on the [__] women restroom
sign yeah and I went let's say that was
locked what would you have done would
you go bust into the guys one was it
that big of emercy yeah I would have
gone into the GU one for sure what if
both them too fatty don't eat at that
ramen restaurant what if both of them
were were uh locked what would you have
done then I really pinched my [__]
tight to secure nothing comes out really
you could do that and then i' be like
okay you know how to do that I mean I'm
this is all in theory
right and i' walked to there's someone
in the front I mean is it like the code
kind or someone they're just they're
both being used they're both being used
[__] [__] what would I do at that moment
I think I'd probably wait a little bit
I'd give it like a minute or two yeah
and if I don't hear the toilet flush I'm
like I need to get out we need to go
somewhere else fast what would it take
for you to have to just pull down your
pants and sit on one of like these trash
cans that are just laying around what
the trash can I'm probably just going to
go around where there's nobody just [__]
on the floor damn we going to be like
that going to bust the LA yeah I have to
what the [__] is a trash can going to do
that's embarrassing keep it nice and
tidy I mean it's embarrassing so you
don't [__] on someone's
Landscaping fertilizer
baby fertilizing that gravel over
there well I'm glad you made it Mama me
too man it's always so [__] sexy you
are shut up so we're back home and look
what this monkey man's doing having the
time of his
life it rained this morning and last
night and this is the remainder of the
rain this the first thing this guy
wanted to
do hey put your that's disgusting put
your underwear or your pants back
up no way okay this is day two after
taica rolled all all over
that little puddle of uh water he
showered got ready for bed it just got
really boring um but today is the night
before Papa's
birthday and because Papa didn't really
get to celebrate his birthday's growing
up he doesn't know how to celebrate them
properly so yes we've been together for
like 15 years now I know how to
celebrate them properly I go like this
Mom thank you for giving birth to me
I'll do whatever you want me to do today
because today's a day that obliterate
your vagina coming out you would say
that no but something along those lines
Jesus Christ and then I'd be like this I
wash her car wash your kitchen wash your
toaster wash the bathroom vacuum the
house and then that's how I spent my
birthday usually maybe that's maybe
that's why I'm such a giving mood you
know you're asking me what do you want
to eat to like what do you want to eat
we go eat what you want to eat what do
you want to do I'm just so used to
that's so ingrained to serve yeah but my
ex or my reasoning behind what I'm
saying where I'm like that's not true
you do know how to what to do is because
because we've been together for 15 years
and I make it a thing every year not a
huge thing cuz we've been pretty busy
but I make it a thing you've been busy
for like 15 years so they're never
they're never
really like a full birthday the way I
see other people do it yeah other people
are different too other people like
should up dress up the red carpet
they'll do photos like it's like like
for us it's like like even when we were
like hustling with JK it's like JK 8
till 12 and then quick birthday for an
hour hour and then o birthday's over 2
to like 9 back to barbell or whatever
you know yeah it's been like that yeah I
mean it's kind of like that this year as
well but you can do whatever you want to
do cuz even you when you got me the
special doughnut it was literally work
all day go pick up the doughnut open in
the car wow and then work
again well I guess you're never going to
have a birthday you actually want okay
dude what the
heck yeah but um
yeah today's the night before his
birthday so I'm already lucky for him it
started on or his birthday's on a
Saturday so I'm like yo it's Friday
let's do it up what do you want he's
like what do you want I'm like oh come
on it's your birthday do you want me to
order some food do you want to go
somewhere so he's going to lay low today
I think we're all going to lay low today
then I'm just following his suit I'm
like today or this weekend literally I'm
going to yes every single thing you want
so charge it up dude let's get it going
cuz I have after today or after this
weekend it's all nose like I can't wait
to say no you know what I'm saying Papa
I got my nose
ready but this weekend is all about
yes thank you you're welcome okay well
on that note we're going to enjoy some
dinner we got a bunch of leftovers um we
got some regular ass chicken some garlic
noodles some broccolini some shrimp and
pesto pasta two strawberries that t
didn't eat from his breakfast
I got like this FICO
bread pesto
garlic um pizza from t r is so bomb um
I'm going to warm that up and yeah we're
just going to make it a lift overnight I
bought some um uh what is it corn a few
days back cuz Tao loves corn and I'm
just like okay these things are going to
go bad I have to boil them so that we
can eat them soon um yeah and I I think
that's
it yeah nothing else Jesus other than
that say good night
Mia say good night Cooper come here good
night see you
lady